I'd love to ask you because you were an early investor in Robyn and you're sort
of, you're in a very nice place of, uh,
being a huge supporter of the sort of wall street bets kind of distributed
power of the people. And at the same time, uh,
because of you being an investor,
like intellectually giving a chance to Robin hood in this kind of chaotic
time of conversations to think about like, well, what did they do? Right?
What did they do wrong?
So you have a kind of a balanced view on the whole thing, which is really nice.
Is there, we've talked about what Robin had did, right. I think,
can you, uh, sort of steel man, uh,
at your Martha's arguments of, uh,
what Robin hood did wrong in the last few days?
Yeah. I mean,
their communication is always the number one issue with these startups, right?
And if you,
you have to get ahead of any problem and you have to put all the bad news out
immediately. And in the case of Robin hood, it seems based on what you know,
has been in the papers and what Robin hood said publicly is that they had this
kind of liquidity crisis, right, where they were being, uh,
because of these exchanges,
telling them you have to put up this amount of money and collateral and them
being pinned at number one in the app store,
there were so many people trying to buy five shares of this stock,
five shares of this meme stock that it kind of broke their system.
And then the people who clear the trades for them, they said,
you got to put up a billion dollars, $2 billion, $3 billion.
We can't do that overnight.
And I think that they were an uncomfortable situation of like going on
TV and saying, we have a liquidity crisis.
Like I could be like a run on the bank,
everybody then logs in at the same time to Robin hood and tries to sell every
share they own, because they're afraid that the whole thing's going to collapse.
Right.
So I think there was this kind of like black Swan event and they probably didn't
communicate it all that well.
At the center of that. This is really interesting.
Maybe you can comment on the nature of communication, uh, Vlad,
the CEO, the guy you met at the bar,
I think at the center of the communication. Right?
So Ilan is an example of a guy who also is at the center of the communication
for his particular set of companies. And that, you know,
on Twitter seems to be a really powerful way to communicate.
And there was something,
this is me saying there was something about Vlad that
sounded like he's hiding stuff that as opposed to
Ilan, it doesn't sound like he's hiding stuff. It could be the nature that the,
the beat, the timing of the conversation, same thing with Mark Zuckerberg,
Mark Zuckerberg, for some reason often sounds like he's hiding something. Yeah.
And then there's like Jack Dorsey as much less so,
and I don't know what that is about the CEO's that makes you trust them and not.
It might be the point in time, um, like in terms of escape, velocity,
uh, you know,
there might be non-disclosures in place that we're not aware of where they're
not allowed to talk about certain relationships.
And, and, and, and that results in this case and that results in you being like
acting weird and nervous and.
Oh, it could just be, the person is nervous, you know? So it's,
it's really hard to be building one of these companies and you're at scale and,
you know, Oh my Lord, the entire thing's coming apart.
And you're the most hated person for that day. You know,
how the rage cycle works. And the,
the media is just so crazy when they get their hooks into something.
I started happening with Uber. We started having with Facebook and even Tesla,
you know,
there were times when people did stupid things with autopilot and it's like,
okay,
somebody's watching a movie and sleeping in their car or leaving the driver's
seat against all the rules of autopilot.
And somehow Tesla's responsible for that.
It's like we have people who stand on top of their motorcycles and drive down
the road on a motorcycle. And we don't blame Yamaha for,
or Harley Davidson versus some idiot standing on the seat of their motorcycle on
a highway, going 60 miles an hour. We just say that person's an idiot.
But when new technology comes out, we blame the technology,
not the person operating it. And if you are going to operate,
uh, we basically vilified and demonized. And I think that that is part of it.
Like when the person at, I remember Airbnb, we always thought,
what if somebody trashes your apartment? And then sure enough,
a bunch of meth heads rented this poor woman's apartment.
She left all of her stuff in it.
And then a bunch of meth heads had a drug party, destroyed her apartment,
ripped up all our photos and went crazy. And we knew that day would happen,
but nobody remembers it now,
but it was the number one story on every news channel because wow,
that's an exciting story. And I just thought to myself,
I wonder if there are any parties in hotel rooms where the hotel rooms being
trashed and people are doing drugs and crazy things. It's like, yes,
that's basically every hotel in Los Angeles right now is being destroyed by some
rock band. That's throwing a TV out the window, like we expected. And, uh,
you know, a hotel, we just didn't expect it in somebodies house with Airbnb.
And then Airbnb created rules around you.
Can't rent an Airbnb for a party and they learn.
So I think there's a learning curve with these companies and they do get to
scale at a level that is unprecedented.
It used to take decades for a company to become an international phenomenon.
Now it happens in two, three, four years. I mean, look at clubhouse.
This thing went from being, you know,
a private beta six months ago to being the number one app in Germany and in
Japan and here, like, just like that. Boom.
And it's because there's an ecosystem that has never existed the app store.
Then there's a payments online, everybody.
And then everybody has a super computer in their pocket. When we,
the thing people got wrong about entrepreneurship technology
and business, you know,
over the last couple of decades was just how big the market was.
And then how quickly you could, um, you know,
achieve relevancy in these markets.
We thought the market was like the 60 million homes were broadband.
And originally it was like maybe 10 or 20, and then it became 60 million.
Then I was like, okay, well, how many,
how many hours are you at your desktop computer? Well,
like probably at our computers for five hours a day,
10 hours a day at work three hours a day on her own. And then I was like, yeah,
nobody's on their desktop computer. Everybody's on their mobile phone. And Oh,
and by the way, they have it with them.
So the people with mobile phones are now using this high-speed device with an
app store, with their credit card in it. In the early days of the internet,
people were scared to put their credit card on the internet.
That was considered a really dumb thing to do.
If you put your credit card on the internet,
you're going to lose all your money. They're gonna,
they're going to hack you or whatever. And now it's just amazing to me,
how quickly when a company hits,
how quickly it can get to a million subscribers or 10 million or a billion.
And users. Right.
And there's all these networks like social networks that allow the spread of the
viral spread of like a new startup, a new company, uh,
a new app to be announced, a podcast, right?
Single thing, just a single meme. We changed the world. Speaking of clubhouse,
I just want to, we're saying so many interesting things, but there were,
there was a magical moment Vlad Nealon on clubhouse. I don't know it was wild.
Yeah. Is there, do you have thoughts about that interaction?
Uh, w which felt like so many, uh,
aspects of this whole situation feels like totally novel, surreal,
like it's defining era like a billionaire.
The richest human on earth is interviewing, uh,
the person at the center of one of the most interesting mass
scale, like, uh, power battles in finance ever.
Uh, perhaps.
Seven movies have been sold on two weeks.
Just think about how fast things are moving Lexus. This thing happens.
Like people had the idea to short the stock. Six months ago,
they start doing their research. They build an army, they execute the trade.
The system goes down,
Robin hood raises three and a half billion dollars in four days.
Elan is interviewing them on clubhouse on Sunday after the Wednesday had
happened. And now here we are. It's 10 days later. Yeah.
Doesn't it feel like it's been 10 months. Yeah. It's been 10 days,
Lex.
Even 10 days, 10 days. There's like a new president, all these things.
And everyone forgot.
By the way.
We also have a set revolution at the Capitol where a bunch of crazy people
who have guns and body armor,
and then a bunch of them who are just yellowing in cosplay,
took over the Capitol.